so you want to make a horror movie well
you came to the right place why try to
be original when you can follow the same
cookie cutter recipe people have been
following for decades are you ready here
we go
first off you need these characters a
white virgin who has great grades in a
perfect life a black friend who listens
to gangsta rap exclusively and just
loves to say oh hell no a blonde friend
who can only really be described as a
super slut and a preppy boyfriend who
acts all macho but is really a tee at
heart next you need a villain we're
gonna go with a masked lunatic it
doesn't really matter what mass he wears
as long as as easy to reproduce as a
silicon children's Halloween costume he
can use a variety of weapons such as
knives a chainsaw claws but make sure he
never uses a practical weapon such as a
gun if he does your movie will be over
in about ten minutes you are allowed to
place your character in one of two
locations a nasty old cabin in the woods
or rickety old house that's it no
exceptions
what's your film really gets going in
the killer slicing and dicing there are
several things that need to happen
number one your characters need to split
up
we should shut up you can see the door
so this red line just down there we're
gonna have to split up deserves its
place we should split up I know it
doesn't make any sense just trust me
number two what's your movie be scary if
the black guy called the cops no once
the killing starts make sure your
character cell phone has horrible
connection point of having a portable
phone idiot instead of more so in order
to get a signal up here
signal no-nothing run arrange my can
anything no bars
I hate themself number three you want to
know what makes horror movies really
scary of course you do jump scares
I don't care where the characters are
make jump out at them and buy them of
course I mean the audience an even
better way to scare your audiences and
make them think there's about to be a
jump scare and then fake them out then
immediately throw a creepy face right
Adam gets them every time
number four make sure your characters
lose control of their basic motor skills
and can't perform simple tasks such as
opening doors and running without
tripping over their own feet number five
the order of death obviously the black
guy dies first followed by the super
slut and then the boyfriend what about
the virgin you made me think I never
kill her I mean it even if your villain
has a butcher knife right up to her
throat in the middle of a forest find a
way for her to make it out alive and
finally number six at the end of your
film you can make the villain get killed
right wrong even if he gets cut up into
tiny little pieces with a chainsaw his
living eye has to snap open in the last
shot of the film if not how do you make
a sequel a prequel trilogy if you want
to keep the money flowing in you got to
keep your killer alive and that's it
follow these simple instructions and you
could have your own cookie cutter horror
movie in no time or I mean you could be
creative with how you choose to scare
people ah who my kid